faire attention il ya quand même
toujours une volonté de l'exécutif qu'il
a cette fois ci mon avis est très
prononcé d'essayer d'affaiblir le
parlement
c'était assez clair alors on le prend on
essaie de l'affaiblir en en mettant
peut-être mais en mettant en montrant du
doigt les parlementaires ça a été le cas
dans cette dans la première loi la
première loi du quinquennat a porté sur
la moralisation entre guillemets de la
vie publique se voulait dire que la
favorisation oui ça voulait dire qu'il y
avait eu moralité delà de la vie
publique
c'était pas le gouvernement voit on ne
va rien à voir là dedans c'est évident
toujours le cas mais on ne peut pas pour
le parlement moralisation et puis
affaiblissement du parlement je pense
que c'est non mais je pense que nul
n'est obligé de faire la première loi
d'un quinquennat là dessus ça veut bien
dire que à ce moment là on considère
qu'il ya une vraie immoralité du
parlement des parlementaires et donc on
affaiblit ou avant tout il faut le
prouver dans ce cas là même si c'est pas
le cas et je crois que ce n'est pas le
cas à ce moment là il ya quand même une
mise sur la sellette de parlementaires
ces mesures pour voler trop belle pour
des meubles pour de mauvaises après soit
on aimerait surtout pour des mesures que
ni le gouvernement ni le gouvernement ni
le président de la république ne
s'applique m
d'accord